Paths and Functions
of Somatic Afferents
and Efferents of
the Head and Neck
Or... The Who,
The What, and
The Where of the
Cranial Nerve
Video 1. Cranial
Nerves 3, 4, and 6 This
material represents
a distillation of
information that can
be found in Moore's
Clinically Oriented
Anatomy, Chapters 8 and
10. For more specific
information about
each cranial nerve,
I recommend reading
chapter 8 and paying
close attention to
the blue boxes slash
blue pages as they
highlight the many
clinically relevant
aspects about this area
of cranial anatomy.
This lecture series
will cover 9 of the 12
cranial nerves. The
special afferents,
cranial nerves 1, 2,
and 8, will be covered
in a future lecture.
Throughout this
lecture, I will make
reference to the endocranium
and the skull as
separate structures.
The reason for
this is because the
hole a cranial
nerve uses to exit
the endocranium may
not always be the
same hole used to
exit the skull.
This will be made clearer
in this second video.
The first cranial nerve
that we will cover
today is cranial
nerve 3, oculomotor.
This is the major motor
nerve for the eye.
The oculomotor nerve
leaves the brain and
courses rostrally towards
the orbit. It runs
lateral to the cella
tercica and inside
the lateral wall of
the cavernous sinus.
The oculomotor nerve
exits the endocranium
via the superior
orbital fissure. After
exiting the endocranium,
oculomotor passes
through the common
tendinous ring. This
is where most of the
extraocular muscles
attach, and it is an
important anatomical
landmark for structures
within the orbit.
Past the ring, oculomotor
splits into two
major divisions, a
superior division and an
inferior division.
The superior division
innervates just two
muscles, the superior ******
and the levator palpebrae
superioris, a muscle
of the upper eyelid.
The inferior division
of oculomotor innervates
medial ******,
inferior ******, and the
inferior oblique. The
inferior division is
also responsible for
sending presynaptic
parasympathetic fibers to
the ciliary ganglion.
From this ganglion,
nerve fibers continue
into the eye as the short
ciliary nerves, where
they innervate the
ciliary body and sphincter
pupillae muscles.
Clinical correlate.
The multiple structures
innervated by oculomotor
can be used to
determine the location
of an oculomotor
lesion. For instance,
pitosis, or drooping
upper eyelid, is a
paralysis or weakness to
the levator palpebrae
superioris muscle.
Drooping eyelids
are a sign of
a lesion to the superior
division of the
oculomotor nerve.
In contrast, a
weakened medial ******
indicates a lesion to
the inferior division
of the nerve. A
complete lesion to
oculomotor results
in the signature down
-and-out presentation
of the affected
eye due to paralysis
of the four
extraocular muscles
controlled by the nerve.
Lastly, an inability
to constrict the eye
against light
suggests damage to the
parasympathetic fibers
traveling to the
sphincter pupillae
muscle, indicating a
potential lesion to
either the short ciliary
nerves or the ciliary
ganglion itself.
This is called anisocoria
and can best be
seen in famed rock legend
David Bowie. Moving
on to cranial nerve 4,
the trochlear nerve.
The trochlear nerve
is the smallest of our
cranial nerves and
is the only nerve to
leave the brain from
its dorsal surface.
All other cranial
nerves leave the
brain from the
ventral surface. From
the brain, the
trochlear nerve
follows the same path
as the oculomotor
nerve within the
cavernous sinus.
The trochlear nerve
passes superior
to the oculomotor
in the sinus
before exiting
the endocranium
through the superior
orbital fissure.
The trochlear nerve
innervates a single
extraocular muscle,
the superior oblique.
The superior oblique
follows a unique
path from the common
tendinous ring to reach
the posterolateral
aspect of the eye.
To accomplish this
feat, the muscle passes
a long tendon through
a fibrous loop that
juts out from the medial
wall of the orbit.
This loop creates
a pulley, which
in Latin is
called a trochlea,
hence where the trochlear
nerve gets its name.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the
trochlear nerve results
in weakness or
paralysis of the
superior oblique,
affecting the
ability to look down
or even straight.
Unopposed actions from
the inferior oblique
and superior ******
cause an upward
and inward deviation
to the affected eye.
The final cranial
nerve that we will be
looking at in this
video is cranial nerve
6, the abducens nerve.
The abducens, or
abducent nerve, leaves
the brain near the
pons medulla junction,
where it pierces the
dura mater near the
clivus of the skull.
From here, the nerve
crawls its way rostrally
towards the cavernous
sinus, following
the same general path
as both the trochlear
and oculomotor
nerve. The abducens
nerve lies furthest
medially within the
cavernous sinus before
it exits the endocranium
through the superior
orbital fissure.
Within the orbit, the
abducens nerve travels
straight to the
lateral ****** muscle,
the only muscle
innervated by this nerve.
Note the AB in abducens.
The name of the
nerve is based on the
function of lateral
******, which is
to abeduct the eye.
Clinical correlate.
Abducens nerve
lesions present as
a weakness or
paralysis of the
corresponding lateral
****** muscle.
The lack of antagonistic
action against
the medial ******
results in the affected
eye turning medially
towards the nose.
Abducens palsy is the
most common palsy of
the nerves that we
have looked at so far.
This is due to the more
medial location of the
abducens nerve within
the cavernous sinus.
This placement puts
the nerve closest
to the internal
carotid artery.
Blood clots in the
cavernous sinus, or
an aneurysm of the
internal carotid
within the sinus,
are more likely to
compress the abducens
nerve compared to
the other nerves
running in the sinus.
This brings us to
the end of video 1.